my whole life I prepared my son to lead
humanity in the fight against the
machines but there was one thing I could
never prepare him for hi I'm Mike
Seymour from FX guide.com for y well
Arne is back and back again in the new
Terminator Genisys fell have been weird
in this time-traveling epic standoff the
Terminator must fight a younger version
of himself digital doubles in our common
place but matching such a well-known
actor in close-up from such an iconic
film with the real actor appearing right
alongside was a major challenge for
visual effects company MPC recent
research into human faces and skin were
all embodied in MPC's incredible
realization of the 1984 version of
Arnold Schwarzenegger the team used
highly complicated skin shaders to fully
retrace the Terminator skin and model
not only the way that light works on the
surface of the skin but through the
various epidermal and subdermal
components including the blood flow the
model was based on a head cast from the
real actor taken in 1984 but then given
dramatically more detail by macro
photography and complex facial scanning
of the real actor today one of the most
complex areas focused on was the
terminators eyes which were meticulously
modeled this along with 13 different
types of hair eyebrows eyelashes stubble
head hair all in all the full character
was over a million polygons plus an
additional third again just for the eyes
teeth and the detail Schwarzenegger
himself provided the key facts poses
that the team could use to help the
younger digital version of the
Terminator come to life the sequence was
shot mainly in your lands on a
blue-screen stage with a young actor
Fred azar standing in for the eyeline
and basic framing but what you see
on-screen is all non-human or should i
say digital just as it should be well
don't forget please subscribe for more
behind the scenes action I might see
more for wide
back